the new movies show dog I love this
movie this is a movie where you're
working with real dog did you like
working with dogs real dogs dogs a great
there are an ego minimizing proposition
working with animals and they had much
better catering there they get as many
takes as they need also always in
character a dog Meryl Streep nothing on
its kennel Rowling's nothing on it's a
method acting I mean gorgeous stuff
these dogs do and I feel that way about
horses well I watch great movies my eye
always goes to the it could be like the
most famous movie in the world and I'm
watching it and I'll my eye always goes
to the horse because the horse doesn't
know he's in one of the greatest movies
of all time and so you're looking at
Lawrence of Arabia yes Spartacus so
you're looking at Citizen Kane or you're
looking at a Humphrey great Humphrey
Bogart classic and there's a horse there
and it's just like I don't know they
don't care they don't care and I love
that I'm really really lovers you have a
dog I do have a dog his name I don't
know I'm just kidding you know root beer
I talk about root beer constantly no I
just wanted you to say it root beer yeah
root beer is my dog terribly trained
relative to these animals but we did
some gambling together in Vegas mmm
mandro pair which is I guess illegal or
something you took the dog into the
Clinton yeah what am i a non-person of
course and she's great with numbers root
beer really she likes to piss everywhere
in the house but she's so good at
numbers you know it's an excellent
excellent animal so
I asked you what kind of dog you had you
said you know root beer likes to piss
everywhere good gambler that's the
weirdest description of a gold clip here
from show dogs I believe anything we
need to know about this this is a
terrific picture and I've been in just
made a great picture with how many
talking dogs you want they have so many
ludicrous talks Stanley Tucci Shaquille
O'Neal RuPaul Alan [ __ ] you're from
1944 let's say let's take a look at this
clip from photos gotta say can't improve
on perfection what's that what's a
bikini wax when the judges look under
the tail it's important I have a clean
view well in that case allow me hey
what's that looks kind of stick oh he's
payback ride hey wait what what's he
doing back there the pain passers-by the
beauty she'll remain wait what
[Applause]
we're waxing here we're waxing here show
dogs it's a great picture it's playing
at the cinema drom near you take the
Coney Island Ferry and see this picture
you